The Joe Rogan Experience Qosmio tour again?
No,
no,
I think that's done.
It's over.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I think so.
Well,
I remember when he was touring,
promoters would not,
I think would think it's not worth the trouble really.
I think so.
Yeah.
I think Louisville to Oregon.
Do you think so?
Yeah,
I think so too.
Yeah.
I think he'll take like a year off.
And then he'll do some shows and people get mad and it'd be,
yeah.
And then like if you know,
the real thing is like the corporate side of it.
Like in other words,
a channel or network that would went to,
let's say host show the special,
but he has such a dedicated,
no one's website following is like what he ended up developing and he's sold,
chose and,
and made millions.
You know,
when people were doing the like download my special thing,
I think he could book a venue,
shoot something and go back to his $5 model and do really well.
No,
I'm sure he could and people would be really interested to see it.
Of course Netflix would have them on.
They still have his old stuff.
I want to be,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
yeah.
I was on a flight after right after all of it went down.
I watched his,
uh,
the special from DC,
which I thought was really interesting to watch it knowing the DC one was that,
is that the latest,
latest one,
2017,
but just to know that it was like right around the corner that he was gonna get
busted.
Yeah.
Beating off in front of people.
It's just,
it's a weird thing to get caught doing too.
Yeah.
I got to all the things that people have done that they got caught doing,
although rape accusations and all the horrible shit,
like his is the most pathetic and also kind of the most innocuous.
Yeah.
It's just humiliating.
Just beating off in front of people.
I know.
It's like his kink.
It's what he likes,
but it could be way worse,
you know?
Like what,
what he actually did not saying it's a good thing to do to people.
No,
it's,
hey,
watch me beat off.
But I know a bunch of people,
he did it too,
apparently laughed.
Yeah,
quite a few comics that I've talked to that know people that he did it too.
Yeah.
I knew somebody.
They did too.
Yeah.
And when she think not happy,
um,
but like,
you know,
I dunno man,
it was like weird.
I knew it for a long time.
That story.
Yeah.
And I,
I mean,
I said it before.
I was like,
well,
I mean I knew it and then like every other person I talked to you in comedy to
it and we were all like,
that's fucked up.
But it also,
I mean this doesn't excuse it at all either,
but there is something about something at least that as you know,
that something somebody did a while ago.
So it's like,
what am I supposed to,
to bring this shit up to him,
you know,
like,
how do you know?
But,
but the other thing is how do you even know that they did it?
Because one of the things that happened during the whole like,
did he do it or do not do it thing before I came out was,
uh,
someone had told me that it was bullshit and that what he had done is take some
pictures with a female comedians with his dick out,
just being silly and stupid and like,
and then tell him,
please delete.
Those pictures were just having fun,
you know,
in trouble.
I mean,
the story I heard was very specific.
Yeah.
And like,
you know,
is basically one of the stories reported in the times and I was like,
I remember hearing that story and the person was not,
you know,
it was pretty upset about it.
And then a lot of people heard the story.
Yeah.
And then,
I dunno,
you know,
another year would go by two years and three years and you're like,
okay,
I mean that's bad.
But like as far as my role in it,
you know,
as somebody who knows the story now,
it was just one of those things where you'd be like,
yeah,
that's fucked up story.
You know?
I mean,
it's not someone that like,
Hey,
you know,
that guy,
he fucking punched someone 15 years ago.
It was a real asshole.
And you're like,
that sucks,
you know?
But 15 years ago is a long time,
right?
I mean,
kind of.
It's like,
is there,
it's not to like minimize the wrong doing,
but like I sent there some part of the conversation about how people mature and
become different people as they get older.
And I'm sure a lot of people that are in their fifties and sixties you go like,
you know who are not celebrities.
You'd be like,
do you know that when this guy was 26 he did this fucking horrible,
stupid thing or something?
You're like,
Jesus,
but you're like,
well,
you know,
as long time ago now,
I mean,
that was kind of at least that part of the conversation exists in this,
right?
It's like,
it's,
it,
it's something really bad and he's being punished.
So that's,
we're not saying that it's,
it's definitely,
it has not been excused because he's being punished,
but it's also old behavior.
Yeah.
Like that's the Dustin Hoffman thing.
Dustin Hoffman,
this is where it gets really strange.
A lot of his stuff was 30 years ago,
1985 and shit.
I think part of the difference too between the Hoffman stuff and Louis and maybe
everybody else is Louise admission.
Right?
That's very different because even like the stuff I heard with Hoffman,
he is like,
he's definitely trying to justify uh,
versions and the behavior and like that's what people did,
you know,
is that what he said?
Oh yeah.
He's like,
you know,
on the set,
like you try to like get,
you know,
you have to break the tension or there's,
there's a monotony to it.
And so people would have these conversations and say,
so it's not,
it's like he's trying to,
it appears that he's trying to be less accountable for what he said.
Whereas Louie was like,
these stories are true.
Right?
So it's,
I think all the,
those things end up affecting how your redemption goes because they're like,
somebody like,
I did this shit,
I was wrong.
And I think in this country,
if people love punishment,
like,
are you punished for the thing you did?
We hate like somebody getting away with something.
So part of him,
I think coming back,
we'll also be that people realize that he paid a price.
Right.
I mean he lost deals.
He lost shows,
lots of money.
Definitely lost a lot of fucking touring money.
Yeah.
It's that day.
Is it?
Probably at least a $50 million day for him,
you know,
with everything together.
So this isn't that crazy.
Yeah.
I mean what a weird kink jerk off in front of people.
I wonder how you develop,
I mean I guess I can imagine how you develop it bit.
Do you think that you could even do that?
Like I was trying to think,
could I even ask them,
Hey,
do you mind if I jerk off in front of you and then just get hard and actually be
like,
well that's the thing.
I imagine he had to be a leaking.
Right.
But like before that like to come that fast,
it had to be something he's thinking about like all day,
you know,
and like hanging out and then like,
Hey,
do you want to hang out?
Like,
do you want to come back or whatever?
And like,
so as he's getting closer to doing it,
I'm sure it's,
it's,
it's the only fuel that's on his mind,
you know?
So it's like,
you asked me that,
I'd be like,
well,
that's not my kink.
So you're like,
hey,
could you go from fully flacid to come?
These people are like,
I don't think so,
man.
I don't think I could do that.
No.
Kinks are fucking weird.
Kinks are weird.
[inaudible].